-The January 6th Committee
revealed a series
of depositions today
from former aides
to President Trump,
who said he was watching TV
as the insurrection unfolded.
Meanwhile, the Secret Service
has mysteriously deleted
text messages from
the day of the coup attempt,
despite requests from Congress
to preserve all records
related to January 6th.
For more on this, it's time
for "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
The January 6th Committee
was back in prime time tonight,
which means
we don't know what happened,
because we taped this
before the hearing.
Although, given how shocking
the previous hearings have been,
I'm not taking anything
off the table.
Maybe you're watching this
right now thinking, "Oh, my God,
I can't believe Trump tried
to commandeer Air Force One
so he could fly to the Capitol,
but then got lost
and crashed
in the Atlantic Ocean,
where he was adrift at sea
for several weeks
and befriended a volley ball
he named Mike Pence."
[ Laughter ]
In fairness,
if you saw a volleyball,
you could definitely be forgiven
for thinking it was Mike Pence.
[ Laughter ]
Or maybe you're sitting at home
right now, thinking,
"I can't believe
Rudy Giuliani..."
Actually, you know what?
Never mind.
Shame on all of us
if we're ever surprised again
by anything Rudy does
from this point forward.
I mean, he already
leaked hair dye
on national television and
posted a video on Twitter
with his shorts
down to his ankles,
swinging a golf club
back and forth
like the world's
[bleep] hypnotist.
[ Laughter ]
"You're getting very sleepy,
and so am I.
Good thing I'm already wearing
my pajama shorts."
[ Laughter ]
So, as we're taping this,
we don't know
exactly what happened,
but the committee did release
an early teaser today --
a series of depositions
with former Trump aides
who all testified that as
the seat of our government
was under attack
by a violent mob,
Trump himself incited, as part
of a carefully orchestrated plot
to overthrow American democracy,
Trump was doing one thing,
and one thing only --
sitting in the White House
dining room, watching TV.
-Was the President
in that private dining room
the whole time that the attack
on the Capitol was going on?
Or did he ever go --
again, only to your knowledge --
to the Oval Office,
to the White House
Situation Room, anywhere else?
-To the best
of my recollection,
he was always
in the dining room.
-What did they say, Mr. Meadows
or the President, at all,
during that brief encounter that
you were in the dining room?
What do you recall?
-I think they --
everyone was watching the TV.
-Do you know whether he was
watching TV in the dining room
when you talked to him
on January 6?
-It's my understanding he
was watching television.
-When you were
in the dining room
in these discussions,
was the violence at the Capitol
visible on the screen?
On the television?
-Yes. Right.
-You got to
give it to Donald Trump.
He was somehow
both the most dangerous
and also the laziest President
in American history.
"Donald Trump in the dining room
with the television"
is the answer to every mystery
in a game of Trump Clue.
I mean, seriously,
they're all talking
about the President
of the United States
the way exhausted parents
talk about a toddler
who needs some chill-out time.
"He's in the dining room,
watching 'Bluey.'
I think we should
just leave him alone."
"Bluey. We love 'Bluey,'
don't we, folks?
We love -- We love 'Bluey.'
We love Bluey's antics.
And let me tell you,
if you love her,
you'll have to go to Australia
because they all talk
like Bluey."
[ Laughter ]
But those depositions
are all consistent
with what he already knew.
Trump was gleefully watching
the violence unfold on TV
and enjoying it.
He was cheering them on
like he was watching
Sunday-night football.
I'm shocked we don't have a
photo of him in the Oval Office
wearing a hat, a foam finger,
and a Jersey that says
"Team Insurrection."
Now... [ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Sometimes you can see
the Photoshop.
I'm not gonna lie.
[ Laughter ]
Sometimes -- Sometimes I feel
like the audience at home
is like, "Whoa,
did that really happen?"
And sometimes they're like, "Ah,
well, that's a Photoshop."
[ Laughter ]
"Look, this stuff's
all happening in real time.
Our graphics team doesn't have
like 24 hours to get ready.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, I'm gonna try
to see it with new eyes.
Can we put it up again
real quick?
That's alright. Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
When he did that, though,
Trump was like,
"You guys better not Photoshop
anything on me later.
I know I'm doing
a very friendly Photoshop pose.
I don't -- No putting
any silly shirts on me."
[ Laughter ]
Now, that's the testimony that
was released before the hearing.
Going into the hearing,
we also had an idea
of who might testify in person
and specifically what
they would testify about.
As we all know by now,
Trump sicced a mob of
armed rioters on the Capitol --
rioters he knew were armed --
and he was essentially
cheering them on
as they tried to find
and kill Mike Pence.
In fact, he even tweeted
angrily at Pence
as the mob was moving through
the Capitol, looking for Pence,
providing further fuel
to the insurrection.
And today we found out more
about what was going on
behind the scenes
as that happened.
-The witnesses are former
Deputy National Security
Adviser Matt Pottinger
and Former Deputy White House
Press Secretary Sarah Matthews,
both of whom resigned
on January 6th.
Sources say Pottinger
is expected to paint
a picture of chaos
in the West Wing,
punctuated by the President's
tweet attacking Pence.
-That's where I knew
that I was leaving that day,
once I read that tweet.
-Matthews is expected
to testify
how alarmed she was
that Trump refused
to quickly call off the mob
after the violence erupted.
-We thought that the President
needed to tweet something,
and tweet something immediately.
-I'm always amazed
by these people
who thought they were working
for a normal President
right up until January 6th.
[ Laughter ]
It must be super easy
to throw surprise parties
for these people.
I mean, they could
even help plan it,
and yet, when everybody
yells "surprise,"
they would probably
wet their pants.
But I do think it's worth
taking a step back to appreciate
what those witnesses
said in that clip.
Everyone around Trump,
including, as we now know,
GOP members of Congress,
Fox News hosts,
and even his own family were
begging him to call off the mob
he instructed to march down
to the Capitol --
a mob Trump knew
was violent and armed,
and Trump refused.
In fact, he did the opposite.
He sent out a tweet
attacking Pence
as the mob was breaching
the Capitol --
a tweet some of the mob
took as a show of support
for what they were doing.
And then when his aides told him
the mob was chanting
"Hang Mike Pence,"
Trump said maybe
he should be hanged.
What else do you need?
If this was an episode
of "Law & Order,"
that would be the part
where McCoy stepped back
from the witness and
said, "I have nothing further,"
and then it would
just fade to black.
And then there'd be that little
final scene in the office
where they're going out
for drinks,
and Schiff puts on
his little weird hat.
"No, 'you' watch too much
'Law & Order'!"
So much crazy [Bleep]
has happened
that it's easy
to forget the details
of any specific Trump scandal,
but I really hope
that particular
sequence of events
is seared in history forever.
Normally, our history textbooks
all have boring names
like "Modern America:
1950 to the Present."
But when they get around
to writing a book about this,
they should just call it
"The Dude Tried to Get
His Own Vice President Killed.
I Mean, What the [Bleep]."
So, that's the preview we got,
going into today's hearing.
But there's also
another aspect to this story
that we were hoping
to hear more about,
and that's what
the Secret Service was up to.
The Committee tried
to get information
from the Secret Service,
but mysteriously,
almost all the text messages
from that day
seem to have vanished.
-The Secret Service says
it cannot recover
the deleted text messages
from January 5th and 6th
of last year.
The Washington Post
is reporting the agency
has no new texts
to provide to Congress
and that any other messages
exchanged between agents
around the time of the attack
were purged.
-I'm sorry. What?
You just deleted all your texts
for one of the most pivotal days
in American history?
I really don't want to
read too much into this,
but it's hard not to.
I mean, it's suspicious
when someone's browser history
is full of porn,
but it's way more suspicious
when their browser history
has just been cleared.
"No, I, uh -- I-I don't really
use the Internet, I guess.
You know?"
[ Laughter ]
How is it possible that we still
have [Bleep] handwritten letters
Alexander Hamilton wrote by
candlelight on parchment
250 years ago,
but text messages sent
by one of the most
technologically advanced
law-enforcement agencies
in the world
from last year
have magically disappeared?
Even if I delete a spam e-mail
from my phone,
it still exists
in like nine different places,
including my iCloud,
for some reason,
even though I have repeatedly
called Apple customer service
and asked them to please stop
saving all those e-mails
offering me free boner pills?
Because I've said it once,
I've said it a hundred times,
the free ones don't work!
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, fellas,
but them's the facts!
[ Laughter ]
You got to spend a little money
if you want results.
[ Laughter ]
And there are lots of reasons
why we'd want to know
what the Secret Service
was talking about on that day.
For one, we already know
that before January 6th,
Pence's chief of staff
warned the Secret Service
that Trump was
putting Pence in danger.
Then, as the attack
was happening,
Pence's agents tried to rush him
away from the Capitol,
and Pence told them,
"I'm not getting in that car."
And then, of course,
there's this insane story,
relayed by Cassidy Hutchinson,
of Trump demanding
that his agents take him
in his Presidential vehicle
to the Capitol to join the mob
in overthrowing the election.
And when they refused,
Hutchinson claims
Trump tried to grab
the steering wheel himself
and then lunged
at one of the agents.
Now, Trump loyalists have since
disputed that story
through
anonymous intermediaries.
But that's all the more reason
why we need
to see the Secret Service
text messages from that day.
Because even if that story
is a little bit true,
I would love to see
what those agents
were texting
to each other about it.
"Agent Stevens,
what happened in the car?"
"POTUS tried to grab the wheel."
"And then what happened?"
"I hit him
with a tranquilizer dart."
"Did he fall asleep?"
"No, it only made him angrier."
[ Laughter ]
"Did you try distracting him
with a chicken nugget?
That usually works?"
"We activated
the emergency nugget protocol,
but it had no effect.
Backup nugget also failed."
"Did POTUS gain
control of vehicle?"
"Yes."
"Did he drive to Capitol?"
"No, he forgot what he was doing
and took us
to Wendy's drive-thru.
Ordered a Frosty.
Chugged it real fast,
then got super bad
ice cream headache."
"Did that calm him down?"
-"No. Tried to choke me again.
We told him Kim Kardashian
was on the phone
and wanted to talk to him, and
that seemed to distract him."
"Was it really her?"
"No,
one of the ages pretended.
He did her voice.
He was like, 'Hi, this is Kim,
I'm such a huge fan.'
POTUS totally bought it.
On our way back
to the White House.
Activate Third Nugget protocol."
This scandal is so bad,
the Department
of Homeland Security
has now reportedly launched
a criminal investigation
into the destruction
of the text messages.
The Secret Service
played a key role
in the events of that day, and
they presumably witnessed
everything Trump was doing,
from watching television
to watching television to...
-Watching television.
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women and children
living with HIV, AIDS,
cancer, and
other serious illnesses.
And they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.